name the algorithm that you can solve this sequentially, not in parallel, that exists in the standard algorithm. And I actually don't think this algorithm exists as a thrust algorithm. I could be wrong about that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 185, recorded on June 5th, 6th, and 7th. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we do phone tag episode number two. And in the episode, we chat about what we've been up to and a algorithm to solve how to find the top K elements in a sequence. Hey, Connor, how are you doing? It's been a while since we've talked. I don't even know.
说出那个可以在标准算法中顺序执行而非并行执行的算法。我其实不认为这个算法在 Thrust 算法库中存在。关于这一点我可能是错的。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 185 期，录制于 6 月 5 日、6 日和 7 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 进行第二期电话录音。在这一期中，我们聊了聊我们最近在忙什么，以及一个解决如何找到序列中前 K 个元素的算法。嘿，Connor，你怎么样？我们已经有一段时间没聊了。我甚至不知道。
It's probably been like four or five, maybe even six weeks. I know you're traveling right now. I have no idea where you are, but I know you've been very busy. So I just figured I would, uh, give you a call and, uh, leave you a message. So, uh, I'm pretty busy too, because, uh, we are moving apartments in about two weeks. It's a very big move moving to a completely different area, which is exactly three blocks north of where we currently live, but on the other side of 2nd Avenue. So that's a big move for me. I can actually see the new apartment building from our current apartment
大概有四五周，甚至六周了吧。我知道你现在在旅行。我不知道你在哪里，但我知道你一直很忙。所以我只是想给你打个电话，给你留个言。我也挺忙的，因为我们大约两周后要搬家。这是一个很大的变动，搬到一个完全不同的区域，其实就在我们目前居住地往北三个街区，但在第二大道的另一边。所以对我来说这是一个大变动。我甚至能从我们现在的公寓看到新公寓大楼。
building. But we're getting a bigger place on a higher floor. And some big and sad news, which is that the famed Bryce coffee table is not going to be coming to the new apartment. It is the one piece of furniture that we are saying goodbye to. It is actually my oldest piece of furniture. When I started working at. It is actually my oldest piece of furniture. When I started working at NVIDIA, I bought myself that coffee table. It was the first nice piece of furniture that I would own. So if anybody, if any listeners are interested in acquiring Bryce's coffee table, you can get it for free. If you can figure out how to get it from here in New York to wherever you are, you can have my coffee table.
但我们要搬到一个楼层更高、空间更大的地方。还有一个重大且令人难过的消息，那就是著名的 Bryce 咖啡桌不会带到新公寓了。这是我们唯一要告别的家具。它其实是我最古老的家具。当我开始在 NVIDIA 工作时，我给自己买了那张咖啡桌。那是我拥有的第一件像样的家具。所以如果任何听众有兴趣获得 Bryce 的咖啡桌，你可以免费拿走。如果你能想办法把它从纽约运到你所在的地方，那它就是你的了。
Anyways, I've been working on ask you about is selection algorithms or like finding the top K of some, you know, set of data. Like I don't want to sort the entire set of data. I just want like the top 10 things or the top, you know, five things. And this is a pretty useful algorithm. It's used in a bunch of places. Apparently it gets used a lot in machine learning. Obviously you can imagine if you're like, you're making a website and you want to, you know, show people the top X results that match some search criteria, you'd probably use some algorithm similar to this. And maybe there's like a related algorithm of finding not just the top 10,
总之，我一直在研究关于选择算法的问题，或者说如何从某个数据集中找到前 K 个元素。比如我不想对整个数据集进行排序。我只是想要前 10 个或者前 5 个东西。这是一个非常有用的算法。它在很多地方都有应用。显然，它在机器学习中被大量使用。你可以想象，如果你正在制作一个网站，想要向人们展示符合某些搜索条件的头 X 个结果，你可能会使用类似于此的算法。也许还有一个相关的算法，不仅仅是找到前 10 个，
but like the, what if I wanted to find like the 11th through the 20th? But I was sort of thinking about this algorithm because I was thinking about whether there's any sort of scan-based approach to implementing this. I mean, obviously, you have to do some sort of sorting here. But there's sort of a different trade-off than the trade-off you have with typical sorting algorithms because, especially in the case where the number of things that you're looking to pick is much smaller than the entire data set, some sorting algorithms like the tonic sort that may not be efficient as you scale up can actually be a win for this sort of problem.
而是比如，如果我想找到第 11 到第 20 个呢？但我一直在思考这个算法，因为我在想是否有任何基于扫描（scan-based）的方法来实现它。我的意思是，显然你必须在这里进行某种排序。但它与典型的排序算法相比，权衡点有所不同，因为特别是当你想要挑选的数量远小于整个数据集时，一些像双调排序（tonic sort）这样在扩展时可能效率不高的算法，实际上可能成为解决这类问题的优势。
So I was just wondering if you were familiar with this problem and if you had any thoughts about it. Hope to hear from you soon. Hey, Bryce. Good to hear from you. I apologize for not being able to do this recording in person. I have indeed been incredibly busy over the last two to three weeks, and you are correct. It has been, I think, five or six weeks since we've talked because the last time we chatted was when we were interviewing Doug Greger, which our listeners know was the last five episodes. Fantastic episodes. I hope all the listeners enjoyed. And currently I am in Pacific Grove, which is right next to Monterey, which is probably more familiar to the listeners. And if you aren't familiar with Monterey, it's at the top of Highway 1 on the Pacific Coast
所以我只是想知道你是否熟悉这个问题，以及你对此有什么想法。希望能尽快收到你的回信。嘿，Bryce。很高兴收到你的消息。我很抱歉没能亲自参与这次录音。过去两三周我确实忙得不可开交，你是对的。我想我们已经有五六周没聊了，因为我们上次聊天还是在采访 Doug Greger 的时候，听众们知道那是最后五期节目。非常棒的节目。希望所有的听众都喜欢。我现在在太平洋丛林市（Pacific Grove），就在蒙特雷（Monterey）旁边，听众们可能对蒙特雷更熟悉。如果你不熟悉蒙特雷，它位于加州太平洋海岸 1 号公路的顶端。
in California. It's a couple hours away from San Jose, or I guess actually an hour and a half. And I'm here at the NVIDIA Research off-site. Technically, it's an on-site for me because I work remotely from Toronto, Canada. And it's been absolutely awesome so far. It's the first time, to be honest, I've been able to meet my coworkers in NVIDIA Research since I joined just under two years ago. And getting to meet your coworkers is quite nice in the post-COVID pandemic days. And yeah, so that's what I'm doing here. We're staying at the Asilomar Conference Center right next to the Pebble Beach, the famous
离圣何塞有几个小时的路程，或者我想实际上是一个半小时。我现在在 NVIDIA 研究部门的线下活动现场。严格来说，对我来说这是个线上活动，因为我在加拿大安大略省多伦多远程工作。到目前为止，一切都非常棒。老实说，这是我加入 NVIDIA 研究部门不到两年以来，第一次能够见到我的同事。在后疫情时代，能见到同事真是太好了。是的，这就是我在这里做的事情。我们住在阿西洛马会议中心（Asilomar Conference Center），就在著名的圆石滩高尔夫球场旁边。
Pebble Beach golf course. And it's absolutely gorgeous. A little bit cold, to be honest. But anyways, that's what I'm doing right now. Last week, I was at the CraftConf 2024 conference in Budapest. Not for the full week, just for a couple days. And that was awesome as well. A couple of really good talks I saw. Got to meet, probably the highlight was getting to meet folks that I hadn't
那里绝对美极了。老实说，有点冷。但总之，这就是我目前在做的事情。上周，我在布达佩斯的 CraftConf 2024 大会上。不是待了整整一周，只是待了几天。那也很棒。我看了几个非常好的演讲。最精彩的部分大概是见到了我以前没见过的人。
met before. I got to meet Richard Feldman, who we've had on the podcast before, link in the show notes. Also got to meet Kevlin Henney for the first time. He's probably one of my favorite speakers of all time. I will link in the show notes, probably my favorite talk of his, which is declarative thinking, declarative practice. And who else did I meet? Jessica Kerr was there who keynoted at CPP North, C++ North 2023, where we will be both at the 2024 edition of that, honestly, in like just a month. And there was a couple other folks. Oh, yeah, Dave Thomas, who used to work at KX, which is the company that sells the Q and KDB Plus executable. And he's given a really good talk in the past at a YOW conference on vector
我见到了 Richard Feldman，我们之前在播客中请过他，节目说明中有链接。我还第一次见到了 Kevlin Henney。他可能是我有史以来最喜欢的演讲者之一。我会在节目说明中链接我最喜欢他的一个演讲，即“声明式思维，声明式实践”。我还见了谁？Jessica Kerr 也在那里，她是 CPP North, C++ North 2023 的主讲人，我们俩都将参加 2024 年的活动，老实说，就在一个月后。还有其他几个人。哦，对了，Dave Thomas，他曾在 KX 工作，那家公司销售 Q 和 KDB Plus 可执行文件。他过去在 YOW 大会上做过一个关于向量思维的非常好的演讲，
thinking, which I will also link in the show notes. And I didn't actually realize this, but he's the individual that organizes the GoTo conferences and the Yao conferences. So anyways, got to meet a bunch of people. And now I'm at the NVIDIA Research Offsite. So yeah, just incredibly busy. I've also been preparing because I've got a poster that I'll be presenting on this evening. Anyways, that's what I've been up to. And to answer your question, have I thought about the top K problem? I am shocked. You actually told me about this probably like a month and a half ago, right before we interviewed Doug. And I wish we were recording this in person because this is an algorithm that we have talked about. There might even be an episode of ADSP that is named the name of the algorithm that is used for solving this.
我也会在节目说明中附上链接。我之前没意识到，但他就是组织 GoTo 大会和 Yao 大会的人。总之，见到了很多人。现在我在 NVIDIA 研究部门的线下活动现场。所以，确实忙得不可开交。我也一直在准备，因为我今晚要展示一张海报。总之，这就是我最近的情况。回答你的问题，我考虑过前 K 个元素的问题吗？我很震惊。你大概在一个半月前，就在我们采访 Doug 之前就跟我提过这个，对吧？我真希望我们是面对面录音的，因为这是我们讨论过的算法。甚至可能有一期 ADSP 节目就是以用于解决这个问题的算法命名的。
I have talked about it in my Better Algorithm Intuition Talk, which is the follow-up to the original Algorithm Intuition Talk. Kate Gregory has talked about this. There's tons of people that have talked about this algorithm. And it's a standard library algorithm. Now you're talking about it from a parallel, you know, is this implementable in terms of a scan perspective, but we got to out of the gate, out of the gate, folks, we got to we got to talk about how you can solve this in with a sequential algorithm that exists. It exists in the algorithm standard library. So I'm going to throw this back over to you, Bryce. Name the algorithm that you can solve this sequentially, not in parallel, that exists in the standard algorithm. And I actually don't think this
我在我的“更好的算法直觉”演讲中谈到过它，那是最初“算法直觉”演讲的后续。Kate Gregory 也谈到过这个。有很多人谈论过这个算法。这是一个标准库算法。现在你从并行的角度谈论它，比如这是否可以从扫描的角度实现，但我们必须开门见山，伙计们，我们必须谈谈如何用现有的顺序算法来解决这个问题。它存在于算法标准库中。所以我把这个问题抛回给你，Bryce。说出那个可以在标准算法中顺序执行而非并行执行的算法。我其实不认为这个算法在 Thrust 算法库中存在。
algorithm exists as a thrust algorithm. I could be wrong about that, but I don't think it actually... So it exists in the C++ algorithm header, but I don't think it exists as a thrust parallel algorithm. Anyways, excited to hear back from you. It'll be nice to record, hopefully in person. I'm also traveling next week en route to NDC Oslo, So we're going to have to find some time to record because then I'm going on vacation for a couple of weeks. And I need to edit these before I go on vacation. Anyways, hope to talk in person soon. Looking forward to hearing back from you. I know that you can do these with either nth element or partial sort. Like what the question is, is how do you efficiently implement nth element or partial sort in parallel? And you are correct that thrust does not have any of these algorithms. There's no nth element, partial sort, et cetera, in Thrust. It's been like a longstanding feature request.
我可能是错的，但我认为它实际上……它存在于 C++ 算法头文件中，但我不认为它作为 Thrust 并行算法存在。总之，很高兴收到你的回信。希望我们能面对面录音。我下周也要去旅行，前往奥斯陆参加 NDC 大会，所以我们得找时间录音，因为之后我要去度假几周。我需要在度假前编辑这些节目。总之，希望很快能面对面交流。期待你的回信。我知道你可以用 nth_element 或 partial_sort 来做这些。问题是，如何高效地并行实现 nth_element 或 partial_sort？你是对的，Thrust 没有这些算法。Thrust 中没有 nth_element、partial_sort 等。这是一个长期以来的功能请求。
What people today do when they want to do this in parallel with Thrust is, like, a lot of people just sort the entire sequence. So I was actually talking to one of our coworkers, Elias, about this the other day, who's looked into these algorithms more than me. And his belief is that the best way to implement these in parallel is with partitioning. And he feels that this is a good approach in particular because partitioning is applicable to like a lot of different problems. So if we add the partitioning primitives that we need to solve selection
人们今天想用 Thrust 并行做这件事时，很多人只是对整个序列进行排序。我前几天和我们的同事 Elias 谈过这件事，他比我更深入地研究了这些算法。他的观点是，并行实现这些算法的最佳方式是分区（partitioning）。他认为这是一种很好的方法，特别是分区适用于许多不同的问题。所以如果我们向 Thrust 和 Cub 添加解决选择、前 K 个元素和部分排序所需的分区原语，那么我们就可以用它们做很多其他事情。所以分区方法的基本思想是，你进行类似基数选择（radix select）或样本选择（sample select）的操作，将所有内容放入 N 个桶中。你要进行多轮放入桶的操作。然后，你知道，比如你想要第 10 个元素，或者你想要第 10 到第 20 个元素，或者你想要前 10 个元素。
and top-k and partial sorting to Thrust and Cobb, then there will be a bunch of other things we can do with them. So the basic idea with partitioning approach is that you do like either a radix select or sample select to put everything into N buckets. And you're going to do multiple rounds of putting things into buckets. And then, so you know, like you want the, you know, 10th element, or you want like the 10th to the 20th elements, or you want like the, the, the 10th to the 20th elements, or you want like the zero to the, like the top 10 elements, the zero to the 10th element.
在将东西放入桶中后，你可以根据你想要的东西，找出可以丢弃哪些桶。现在在 Thrust 和 Cub 中，我们确实有一个分区原语，但它是双向分区，即二元分区。所以，你有一个分区函数，你要么在组内，要么在组外。它将输入分成两个不同的组。但我们需要的是一个多路分区原语，而不是一个接收元素并返回布尔值（判断是否通过谓词）的函数，你需要一个接收项目并返回索引（属于哪个桶）的函数。然后多路分区会将输入分成 N 个桶。然后，你迭代地进行这个过程。你继续进行选择。所以，在基数选择的情况下，你是在遍历数字的实际位。
And after you have the things into buckets, you can figure out based on what things you want, which of these buckets you can get rid of. Now in, in Frost and Cub today, we do have a partitioning primitive, but it's a two-way partitioning, a binary partitioning. So, you have a partition function and you are either in the group or out of the group. So, it splits the input into two different groups. But what we need is we need a multi-way partitioning primitive that instead of a function that takes, you know, an element and returns a bool of whether or not it passes the predicate, you need a function that takes an item and returns an index into, you know, which bucket does this belong into? And then the partitioning, the multi-way partitioning will split the input up into N buckets. And then, you know, you do this process iteratively. You continue doing selection down. So, in the case of like radix selection, you're going through the actual bits of the
现在，这里的一个挑战是，我们对可基数选择的事物使用基数选择进行并行排序。所以像整数这样的东西，我们可以遍历并查看它们的每一位来对它们进行排序。但对于基数排序，它是最低有效位基数排序。所以我们从低位开始，
number. Now, one of the challenges here, we use radix selection for parallel sort of things that are radix selectable. So things like ints, you know, things that like we can go through and like look at each one of their bits to sort them. But for radix sort, it's a least significant bit radix sort. So we start from the low bit
然后我们做一些黑魔法。这之所以重要，原因之一是当你从低位开始时，想象一下对整数进行排序，你从低位开始。这个选择机制在你的数据中有多少偏差？所有东西最终都进入一个桶的可能性有多大？好吧，如果所有数字都是偶数，那么你可能会最终进入一个桶。但如果你有各种各样的数字，比如不同数量级的数字，你就没问题。然后你移动到下一个最高位，再下一个，以此类推。现在，进行最低有效位基数排序的一大优势是，如果你有一组数字，比如你有 100 万个从 0 到 10,000 的整数。
and then we do some like black magic. And one of the reasons why this is significant is that when you start with the low bit, imagine like sorting ints and you're starting with the low bit. How much bias do you have in your data for this selection mechanism? How likely is it that like everything is going to end up in one bucket? Well, if everything, if all your numbers are even, then you might end up in one bucket. But like, if, you know, you've got, you've got like a variety of numbers, like, you know, of different orders of magnitude, you're, you're, you're fine. And then you move on to the next highest bit, the next highest, the next highest, etc. Now, one of the big advantages of doing this least significant bit radix sorting is that if you have a set of numbers that, you know, like maybe you've got like a million ints from like zero to 10,000.
或者即使你有 100 万个从 0 到 10 亿或 100 万的整数。在这两种情况下，即使对于可能的值有巨大的范围，你最终在有效位方面会有很多未使用的位。所以，如果你从有效位开始选择，那么你最终会得到很多偏差，对吧？如果只有小数字，而你从左侧开始，那么所有东西最终都会进入同一个桶，因为前几位对每个人来说都是零。所以对于基数排序，我们能够绕过这个问题，因为我们从另一侧开始。但由于我还不完全理解的原因，对于部分排序、选择和前 K 个元素，
Or even if you've got like a million ints from like zero to like, you know, a billion or a million. In either case there, even with that huge range of numbers for what your possible values are, you end up with a lot of unused bits on the significant side of things. And so, if you start your selection on the significant side, then you'd end up with a lot of bias, right? That if like, if you've got only small numbers and you're starting on the left side, then everything's going to end up in the same bucket because those first few bits are going to be zero for everybody. So for radix sort, we're able to get around this because we start from the other side. But for reasons that I don't fully understand yet, for partial sort, selection, and top K,
我们不能那样做，因为基本上对于基数排序，我们最终无论如何都要遍历所有的位。所以从哪个方向开始并不重要。但当你做选择问题时，你必须从左边开始。同样，由于我还不完全理解的原因，但这意味着你的选择函数可能会出现偏差，你可能会最终
we can't do that because basically for radix sort, we end up going through all the bits anyways. And so like, it doesn't matter which direction we start from. But when you're doing some selection problem, you have to start from the left. Again, for reasons I don't fully understand but the implication of this is that you can end up with like bias in your selection function where you can end up with
你想把东西分成 100 个桶，但实际上把所有东西都放进了一个或两个桶里，诸如此类。这就是这个问题空间在并行处理时面临的挑战之一。对于那些不可基数选择的事物，你需要进行某种样本选择，这有点像样本排序的基础。
you wanted to sort things into 100 buckets but you ended up actually putting everything into one or two buckets something like that. And so that's one of the challenges with this problem space, doing this in parallel. And then for things that are not radix selectable, you need to do some sort of sample select, which is sort of like the basis of something like sample sorts.
这里的想法是，你将从数据集中任意、随机地挑选一些枢轴元素。然后你会说，好的，我们将根据这些进行选择。我们将根据这些东西分区到桶中。我认为弄清楚如何挑选好的样本也有点棘手。是的。所以，你知道，我一直在想的另一件事是，如果你只是想找到，所以选择的情况是一个有趣的例子，比如我只是想要第 50 个或第 500 个元素，或者只是中位数。
The idea here is that you're going to just pick some pivot elements arbitrarily, randomly from within the data set. And then you're going to say like, okay, we're going to select based on these. We're going to partition into buckets based on these things. And figuring out how to pick good samples is also, I think, a little bit tricky. Yeah. So, you know, the other thing that I've been thinking about a bit, too, is if you, like, if you just want to find, so the case of selection is, like, an interesting one where it's, like, I just want, like, the, you know, the 50th or the 500th element or just like the medium and median element.
我觉得你应该能够做得比必须对序列进行任何形式的部分排序或部分分区更好。我觉得，我知道我几乎可以肯定事实并非如此，但我觉得这应该是一件可以通过归约（reduction）来完成的事情。你知道，你可以做一个最大值归约来找到最大值。如果你想找到第二大值，你也可以做一个归约来找到它。你必须存储最大值是多少，然后还要存储第二大值。如果你想找到第 10 大元素，如果你愿意存储一个 10 个元素的缓冲区，并将其与你的归约元素、归约运算符一起复制，然后你必须有一种组合它的方法，大概是这样，但我认为这不是问题。那么你就可以在不必进行完整排序的情况下做到这一点。而且，我认为我本质上想说的是，在 K 很小的情况下，比如你想要做前 K 个元素，或者你想要做选择，比如在接近末尾的地方，你可以做更高效的归约，甚至可能是基于扫描的算法。总之，我现在有点语无伦次了。我，我会把这条消息发给你，然后我得走了，因为我刚刚意识到我下周要搬家，现在我得去奥尔巴尼接女朋友，而不是像我计划的那样在周二。所以我基本上只剩下三天时间在这个公寓里，还有很多事情要做。好吧，我会很快和你聊的，伙计，等你结束旅行。听起来你玩得很开心。希望你在那边有美好的天气。而且，我真的很高兴你能参加所有这些会议。我知道你有多么享受并从中汲取能量。所以，下次我们聊天时，我应该已经在新公寓了。
And it just feels to me like you should be able to do something better than having to do any form of like partial sorting or partial partitioning of the sequence. It feels to me, I know I'm almost certain it's not the case, but it feels to me like it should be something that should, you should be able to do by reduction. You know, you can do a max reduction to find the maximum. If you wanted to find, you know, the second from maximum, you could also do a reduction to find that. You would have to, you know, store whatever the maximum is and then also store the second
希望它的音响效果会更好，背景噪音会少一点。它在 37 楼，而不是我们现在住的 11 楼。所以我们正在向上搬。这意味着它会安静一点。总之，享受你剩下的旅程。我会很快和你联系。嘿，Bryce，刚收到你的消息。是的，祝你搬家顺利。
from the maximum. And if you want to find like the, you know, the 10th max element, if you're willing to store, you know, a buffer of 10 elements and copy that around with, like, a state that's copied with your reduction element, your reduction operator, and then you'd have to have some way of combining it, presumably, but it's not, I think, an issue. Then you could do that without having to like do a full sort um and uh you know i think essentially what i'm getting at is that in the case where like your your your k is small um like you like you want to do top k with a small k or you want to do selection with like a with a where you want a small, like something near the front of the end, um, you can do more efficient, uh, uh, reduction or maybe even scan based, um, algorithms. Anyways, I'm just rambling now a little bit at this point. Um, I, uh, I will send you this message and then I got to go because, uh, it's just,
听起来你这个周末会忙得不可开交，这也可能意味着我们无法录制 186 到 188 期节目。所以我们得想办法解决这个月剩下的时间。但那是未来的我们需要解决的问题。现在是周四，我想我们昨天交换了消息，或者可能是在我们进行 NVIDIA 研究部门线下活动期间。我现在回到了圣克拉拉，离 NVIDIA 总部只有五分钟路程，明天我会在那里工作半天，然后飞回多伦多。是的，研究部门的线下活动结束了。非常棒。很高兴见到同事、其他研究团队的人，我平时和他们交流不多。有很多很棒的想法。是的，期待着，我不确定明年是否还会有，但我认为他们肯定每两年会做一次。我想也许线下的活动每两年一次，还有一个虚拟的。我其实不太确定。总之，也期待听到咖啡桌是否找到了新家，因为我不确定是否有听众联系过，正如你在上一条消息中提到的，或者那是两条消息前，如果有人想获得 Bryce 的咖啡桌，它是他们的了。那是一张相当大的咖啡桌，所以我不确定如果他们不在纽约，他们怎么把它弄走。总之，回到并行 nth_element 的话题。你在第一条消息中没有提到它，但你确实回答了我的问题。
just like now hitting me that like i'm moving next week and now i gotta leave to go to albany to pick up the girlfriend on sunday instead of uh like tuesday like i planned so i basically got like three days left in this apartment and a lot of stuff to do so well uh i will uh talk to you soon buddy once you you stop all your traveling. It sounds like you're having a great time. I hope you've got some beautiful weather down there. And, yeah, I'm really glad that you're getting to go to all these conferences. I know how much you enjoy and thrive on that energy. So, yeah, next time we talk, I should be in the new apartment.
这个算法的名字，可能大多数听众都在想，就是 C++ 中的 nth_element，它能让你得到如果序列已排序后的第 n 个元素。所以你可以认为，如果你需要找到中位数或百分位数，这就是你需要的确切算法。而且 nth_element 的属性之一是，对于默认的二元操作，它会将所有小于该元素和大于该元素的值分别分区到左侧和右侧。我很确定你可以自定义 nth_element 上的二元操作。你也提到你可以用 partial_sort 来解决这个问题。然而，你说你的目标是并行解决这个问题。正如你提到的，
And hopefully it will have better acoustics, a little bit less background noise. It's on the 37th floor as opposed to the 11th floor where we're at right now. So we're moving on up in the world. And that means it's a little bit quieter. Anyways, enjoy the rest of your travels. And I will talk to you soon. Hey, Bryce, just got your message. And yeah, good luck with all the moving.
没有 Thrust 的 nth_element。所以问题是该怎么办。当你解释不同的分区和基数排序解决方案时，我在脑子里想，K 有多大？或者更准确地说，K 有多小？因为如果它足够小，你只需做一个归约，然后存储所有的值。这实际上就是你在消息末尾所说的。所以当你提到分区和基数排序时，我在想，如果 K 足够小，只需做一个归约。然后如果 K 足够大，只需做一个排序。所以是的，问题是，如果 K 不够小到可以做归约，也不够大到可以对整个东西进行排序，你该怎么办？我脑子里其实没有现成的答案。所以也许我们会在后续节目中讨论这个问题。因为是的，我脑子里没有什么好主意。
It sounds like you're going to have an incredibly busy weekend, which also probably means we're not going to be able to record episodes 186 through 188. So we will have to figure out what we're going to do for the rest of the month. But that is a problem for future us. And I it is Thursday, I think we exchanged messages yesterday, or potentially, I think it was yesterday while we were mid NVIDIA research offsite. I am now back in Santa Clara, just like five minutes away from the NVIDIA headquarters, where I'll be working for half a day tomorrow before I fly back to Toronto. And yeah, the research offsite's over. It was a blast. Awesome to meet, you know, coworkers, folks, and other research teams that I don't really interact with much. Lots of awesome ideas. And yeah, looking forward to, I'm not sure if there's going to be
分区采用一元谓词，有点像 nth_element 所做的事情，但它不能保证你在第 n 个位置拥有如果数据已排序后会出现在那里的值。它基本上只是做一个谓词排序。所有通过谓词的东西都在前面，所有未通过谓词的东西都在后面，但除了这一点之外，你没有任何其他保证。所以这并不能真正帮到你多少。是的，我会考虑这个，因为我认为这已经让我们接近 30 分钟的标记了，我们会在未来的节目中重新审视这个问题。所以你可能听不到这个，因为你不听节目，但祝你搬家顺利。希望我们能找到时间聊天。如果我们不这样做，我不确定 186 期节目会发生什么，但听众们，我保证会有内容的。我保证会有内容的。总之，祝你和 Ramona 搬家顺利。我很高兴你要搬到更高的楼层，而且会更安静。我期待着等你搬完家，我也结束旅行后和你聊天。是的，到那时再聊。请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，
one next year, but I think they're definitely doing one once every two years. I think maybe the on-site one will be every two years and there's a virtual one. I'm not actually entirely sure. Anyways, also looking forward to hearing if the coffee table finds a home, because I'm not sure if any listeners have reached out, as you mentioned in your last message, or was it two messages ago, if someone is looking to acquire Bryce's coffee table, it is theirs for the taking. It is a rather large coffee table, so I'm not sure how, if they're not in New York, how they're going to get it. Anyways, back to the topic of the parallel nth element. So you didn't mention it in your first message, but you did answer my question.
获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。这不是口号。我们的口号是带有信息碎片的混乱。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
The name of the algorithm, probably most of the listeners were thinking about it, is nth element in C++, which gets you the nth element if it were in a sorted sequence. So you can think of this as kind of if you need to find the median or a percentile, this is the exact algorithm that you need. And also one of the properties of the nth element is that it will partition all the values that are less than the element and greater than the element on the left and right sides for the default binary operation. I'm pretty sure you can customize the binary operation on nth element. And you also mentioned you could solve this with partial sort. However, you said that your goal was to solve this in parallel. And as you mentioned,
这个算法的名字，可能大多数听众都已经想到了，就是 C++ 中的 nth_element，它能帮你找到如果序列排好序后处于第 n 个位置的元素。所以你可以把它看作是如果你需要寻找中位数或百分位数时，正好需要的算法。此外，nth_element 的一个特性是，对于默认的二元运算，它会将所有小于该元素的值和大于该元素的值分别划分到左侧和右侧。我很确定你可以自定义 nth_element 的二元运算。你还提到可以用部分排序（partial sort）来解决这个问题。然而，你说你的目标是并行解决它。正如你提到的，
there is no thrust nth element. So the question is what to do. While you were explaining the different partitioning and radix sort solutions, I was thinking in my head, how large is K or more precisely, how small is K? Because if it's small enough, you could just do a reduction and then store all the values. And that is actually what you said at the end of your message. So I was while you were mentioning the partitioning and radix sorting, I was thinking, if K is small enough, just do a reduce. And then if K is large enough, just do a sort. So yeah, the question is, if k is not small enough to do a reduction and not large enough to just sort the whole thing, what do you do? I don't actually know off the top of my head. So maybe we will discuss this in a follow-up episode. Because yeah, I don't have any great
Thrust 库中没有 nth_element。所以问题在于该怎么做。当你在解释不同的划分和基数排序解决方案时，我脑子里在想，K 有多大，或者更准确地说，K 有多小？因为如果它足够小，你完全可以做一个归约（reduction），然后存储所有的值。这实际上就是你在消息末尾所说的。所以当你在提到划分和基数排序时，我在想，如果 K 足够小，就做归约；如果 K 足够大，就做排序。所以，问题是，如果 K 不够小到可以做归约，也不够大到可以直接对整个序列进行排序，那该怎么办？我目前还没想到。所以也许我们会在后续的节目中讨论这个问题。因为我确实没有太好的
ideas off the top of my head. A partition takes a unary predicate and kind of does what nth element does, but it doesn't guarantee you that at the nth spot you have the value that would be there if the data was sorted. It just basically does a predicate sort. Everything that passes the predicate goes at the front and everything that fails the predicate goes at the back, but you don't have any other guarantees other than that. So that doesn't really help you much. Yeah, I'll think about this because I think this is bringing us to about the 30 minute mark and we'll revisit this problem in a future episode. So you're probably not going to hear this because you don't listen to the episodes, but good luck moving. Hopefully we'll find some time to chat. If we don't, I'm not exactly sure what's going to happen for episode
想法。partition 接受一个一元谓词，其作用有点像 nth_element，但它不能保证第 n 个位置上的值就是数据排序后该位置上的值。它基本上只是做了一个谓词排序。所有通过谓词的元素都会被放到前面，所有未通过的元素会被放到后面，除此之外没有任何其他保证。所以这并不能帮上什么忙。是的，我会考虑一下，因为我觉得我们快到 30 分钟了，我们会在未来的节目中重新讨论这个问题。所以你可能听不到这段话，因为你不听我们的节目，但祝你搬家顺利。希望我们能找到时间聊天。如果我们没能聊上，我不确定第 186 期节目会怎样，
186, but the listeners, I promise there'll be something. I promise there'll be something. Anyways, good luck with the move to both you and Ramona. I'm happy you're moving to a higher floor and that it'll be quieter. And I'm looking forward to chatting once you'veona. I'm happy you're moving to a higher floor and that it'll be quieter. And I'm looking forward to chatting once you've moved and I'm done traveling. And yeah, we'll talk to you then. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com
但听众们，我保证会有内容的。我保证会有内容的。总之，祝你和 Ramona 搬家顺利。很高兴你们搬到了更高的楼层，那里会更安静。我很期待等你搬完家、我结束旅行后我们再聊天。到时候再聊。请务必查看节目说明，可以在你的播客应用中查看，或者访问 ADSPthepodcast.com
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
获取今天节目中提到的所有内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢这期节目，祝你有愉快的一天。低质量，高产量。这就是我们播客的口号。那不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息碎片的混乱。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。